one of the pieces that i'm absolutely
fascinated by at the moment is the
geopolitical and also the
intra-american competition for bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies we've seen miami
try to become the bitcoin capital of the
world we've seen texas everything from
local politicians all the way up to the
governor saying that they want to be the
bitcoin capital of the world especially
around mining we've seen wyoming and
senator lummus put their flag in the
ground and say we want to be the leader
we're going to create a legal framework
we're going to lead from the front and
now we see the brand new new york city
mayor eric adams elected last night in a
landslide victory literally during his
acceptance speech say
he's going to make nyc the home of
bitcoin he's going to bring back all the
businesses that left during the pandemic
when you have this level of competition
just within the united states you have
cities and states all competing with
each other to see who can get the
bitcoin infrastructure put in their
geography who can elicit and support the
people who like bitcoin who hold bitcoin
who are building around bitcoin to come
and move to their jurisdiction this is
healthy competition is healthy you now
have multiple jurisdictions within the
united states all competing with each
other to see who can provide the best
experience and ultimately you i and the
rest of the citizens they win when
there's competition among
uh geographies and jurisdictions but
it's not just in the united states
we also see like places in portugal
where they're literally saying they're
zero percent crypto tax and they're zero
percent capital gains tax see in places
like el salvador say move here and you
won't have to pay any sort of capital
gains tax if you hold bitcoin or you
support those types of businesses and
infrastructure they've made a legal
tender they've handed out bitcoin to
their citizens around the world
governments and politicians are waking
up to the fact that there is a global
competition going on everyone is
competing
how can we get
the bitcoin infrastructure built out in
our country or in our jurisdiction how
can we get the people who hold this
asset to come and move to our location
and how can we continue to incentivize
innovation economic prosperity and job
creation
well
if you one way that you want to do it
would be to find one of the fastest
growing if not the fastest growing
technology industries in the world and
say we want to be a leader there and
that's what miami texas wyoming and now
new york city are all saying we've got
this video from the mayor
newly elected of new york city eric
adams last night during his acceptance
speech
he hits all the right talking points
time will tell
if he actually ends up executing on it
we're going to bring businesses here
we're going to become the center of life
science the center of cyber security the
center
of self-driving cars drones the center
of bitcoins we're going to be the center
of all the technology
miami you had your run we're bringing
our business
[Applause]
now i do have to say one thing he said
bitcoins with the s i'm gonna give him
i'm gonna give him the benefit of the
doubt that that was a freudian slip that
he added to s by accident uh but if he
if he's gonna continue to say bitcoins
i'm out already uh but i do think that
there's a lot of people who want that
message it's a very similar message to
what the uh mayor of miami has been
saying we are going to be the leader in
everything from bitcoin to other types
of technology and we're gonna push
forward i believe that this is going to
be the political message that more and
more people want to hear and therefore
you're gonna hear it more and more from
various jurisdictions all the way down
to cool valley missouri where they're
handing out bitcoin to their citizens
all the way up to new york city the big
apple the financial capital of the world
now here's my challenge to eric adams
get rid of the bit license
if you really want to make it the
capital of bitcoin cryptocurrencies get
rid of the bit license if you do that
people take it seriously people will say
this guy means business this guy is
trying to make it easier to go ahead and
create businesses here there should be
no reason why if i start a traditional
financial firm or a fintech that doesn't
deal in bitcoin or cryptocurrencies i
actually have an easier time getting
into the market and servicing my
customers then if i simply support a
digital currency or digital asset then
all of a sudden it's harder for me
there's actually more regulation there's
more obstacles there's more friction in
the financial capital of the world to
start a bitcoin or crypto company than
there is to start a traditional
financial or fintech firm it's not how
it should be you want to be the leader
lead from the front get rid of the bit
license if you do that i think there's a
lot of people around the world they'll
applaud you i'll be the first one to say
hey he means business
new york's a financial capital of the
world right new york city uh
traditionally wall street i hope this
isn't a pr stunt right just kind of
using clickbait and say hey bitcoin
people like that so let me go ahead and
just say that one of my speeches i don't
believe it is i think he really uh he
really
wants to advocate for the blue-collar
worker um and that's exactly what kind
of bitcoin does it puts everyone on a
level playing field with the monetary
policy and like the inequality that we
have today um look and if he continues
to implement this idea of bitcoin in new
york city it's only good for the
industry um he did call out miami a
little bit which i'm obviously a very
very big fan of so i got to give you a
little little down vote for that one but
uh good for him and uh he also talked
about government spending and how he
wants to cut 500 million dollars from
the budget um every year good i think
our government has a spending problem
and uh i wish him nothing but the best
good for eric it's pretty crazy to hear
uh politicians and government officials
talking about bitcoin in this way right
just so openly and saying hey look this
is gonna be the capital we're gonna
we're gonna uh foster innovation here
when it comes to these assets and stuff
because you know five ten years ago uh
people would have dreamed of that and
now it's kind of becoming commonplace
i am cheering for him and i'm cheering
for the city of new york right i
actually think that uh it's been really
bad to the point where we all moved we
left uh we literally voted with our
wallets and our feet see ya
but i do think that there's a chance
that uh with the right leadership they
can come back and it sounds like
everything i've heard everyone that i
know that knows him or has met him has
absolutely glowing reviews so i am uh
optimistic for new york city optimistic
for uh his work and i'm hoping that uh
he ends up uh being successful for not
only for his own sake but for uh for all
the citizens that are there right